[Music]
you
hello and welcome to today's panel MBA
student insights consumer focused
careers at Stanford GSB my name is
Rebecca Ackerman and I'm a second year
MBA student here at the GSB I'm joined
by christina LaMarca and Faiza Asma two
of my classmates and MBA to students as
well they are each pursuing career
interest in the consumer focused
business space and in our time together
we'll be talking about the student
experience here at the GSB and how we're
using it to prepare for careers after
school please be aware that we won't be
talking about the admissions process the
application or financial aid today you
can consult the website or contact the
MBA admissions office for that
information
now let's begin with introductions as I
mentioned before I'm currently an MBA -
prior to the GSB I lived in Houston
Texas where I worked as a technology
consultant before transitioning into
strategic communications and strategy
for an oil and gas company I came to the
GSB to pursue a career shift into
marketing at a consumer focused company
and I've used my experiences here to
explore that space now turning to
Christina I'd love for you to introduce
yourself thank you
so my name is Christina lamarka I'm from
Italy and prior to coming to the GSB I
was management consultant based in
London and later in Australia and that I
work for an oil and gas company as well
for a year before coming here and I came
because myself - I wanted to move in
transitioning to the consumer retail
space
but at the time I didn't know really
where thank you and I'd like to have
Pfizer introduced herself as well of
course my name is Maya I'm from Panama
originally I worked three years at
Procter & Gamble doing brand management
across Latin America for brands such as
pampers internment had a great time but
I realized that I was moved as I was
moving up in my career there were some
skills that I still needed to develop so
I came in the GSB
how to round up those skills wonderful
thank you so much we're so glad to have
both of you here with us today so I'd
like to go ahead and dive in we've heard
from the traditional route into this
space as well as a more untraditional
route so I'd like to just hear a little
bit about what your decision criteria
was when you decided to apply to the GSB
so for me I guess there were other
schools in other cities that maybe
looked more appealing from a consumer
point of view such as for example London
or New York but where really drove me to
Stanford was the possibility to actually
experience the Silicon Valley culture
and see what applications might have
into the consumer and retail space also
was I think plenty of alumni from
Stanford that I had either started
consumer retail companies home had
covered prominent positions in larger
corporations say the club seemed to me
that to have a very strong reputation in
my case when I was looking at what
schools to apply to the GSB definitely
stood out because two of things that I
was looking for were developing my soft
skills so managing others how to have
different conversations how do project
power and project confidence and the GSB
definitely had the best professors for
those courses so I knew that I wanted to
apply to the GSB I also really like the
opportunities to explore topics outside
of the GSB Stanford lets you take
classes as a graduate student in any of
the schools and that's a great tool to
have as a leader but when you don't know
exactly what industry you might want to
go to after the GSB I've had a very
similar experience I came to the GSB
because of a mix of both the culture and
the relativity to the Silicon Valley so
coming from a tech background
that was a really good segue into
understanding how that really related to
the consumer space and there's just so
many different experiences as you guys
know being able to go visit companies
are having some of those entrepreneurs
come to campus and then the exposure to
developing both the soft and hard skills
I think it's pretty unparalleled and
other experiences so really really glad
I made the choice to come here so
starting to dive into some of the
academics you talked about if either
some of the soft skills that you've
developed if you can share some of what
your favorite classes have been to help
you develop some of those I have a two
favorite classes that I've taken and
they're in the opposite spectrum of hard
and soft skill the first one it's gonna
be a GSB classic it's touchy feely your
interpersonal dynamics I think it really
helped me open my eyes in terms of how
do I come across to other people and
where am I not being a fun efficient
communicator so I think that's those are
learnings that I'm going to keep forever
and on the other spectrum the other like
extreme I really enjoyed optimization
and simulation osm as it's famously
called as I was taking that class my
initial thought was if I knew this a
year ago I would have saved so many
hours of my life just in terms of
optimizing marketing budgets or
calculating our eyes or just being more
efficient overall so those are the two
classes that I would recommend everyone
going into CPG or going into a consumer
focused cause to definitely take and I
imagine did the name scare you off at
first imagine you're going to get so
much value from it I know like so osm is
not a required class I'm sorry is the
required size as in you have to take it
as part as your foundations curriculum
your first year if I had to choose it on
my own I don't know if I would've just
because it sounds intimidating but the
fact that Stanford thinks things ahead
and knows what kind of courses are gonna
be useful in your life like was just
such a huge help thank you Christina any
courses that stand out for you that have
directly related to a career in this
space yes so for me
I guess the first one was product lounge
that we took last year and it's it's an
advanced marketing class with the with
yes with Lee Bob and I wasn't familiar
with the space and so it really helped
me understand how customers interacts
with the product another class that was
really helpful was an across the street
class at the design school and there we
basically focused on need finding so
it's part of the design thinking process
they are for which famous is extremely
for which temper is extremely famous are
for and their I really developed my
skills in finding problems that matter
to customers and developing products
that actually address those problems
those were my two highlights great I
think that for me a couple that really
stood out to me actually apart from
interpersonal dynamics which you
mentioned and product launch where I
took a class on consumer search and
marketing so learning how to leverage
tools such as Google Adwords and
Facebook advertising to actually
understand how you place an ad so if
you're looking at a website or looking
at Facebook and you have an ad that pops
up that's relatively familiar to
something that you might have just been
looking at we learned actually how that
happens and for me that was an extremely
valuable learning that I was actually
able to take forward into my summer
experiences and my summer internships so
that was a really valuable course for me
and then I'm also currently in a course
called startup garage and I know that
christina has had an experience in that
as well but you actually get to test out
building your own product and learning
how to acquire customers and how do you
get close to your consumers how do you
interview them and how do you really
touch base to understand what a core
need of that market is and so for me
I've learned a lot of really essential
marketing and consumer facing tactics
that have been really valuable for me
and my career if I choose to go to
entrepreneurship router if I choose to
go the big business route you're always
going to have customers so those have
been two really valuable experiences for
me
so apart from the academics as I know
and I'm sure you guys can all relate to
the GSB offers so many different
experiences and as much as we are in
classes we're also taking part in a
number of different activities so maybe
you can talk about some of the clubs or
other extracurricular experiences you've
had sure
so of course there's the retail and
consumer Club and for example just
yesterday stitch fix came and told us
about basically their story from the
very origin in 2012 until the IPO it was
extremely interesting its senior
management that comes and you can ask a
very open questions and they're happy to
respond and then another experience from
last year was being a part in the
marketing team of the winter gala it's a
charity gala that the GSB organizes that
the students at the GSB organized and
that was a good way for me to come
together with classmates that I would
have not out of wise mad and it was my
first marketing experience I was also
very interesting because I've had more
of a traditional background when I came
to the GSB I was looking to expand those
skills into consumer spaces that I might
not have access to before so I've been
very involved with the arts community
entertainment Club and the education
Club the arts main entertainment Club
because it's such a different industry
that I'm very curious to see how
consumers operating such an industry but
I'm not necessarily gonna go into but
it's good to flex those muscles in terms
of understanding different different
types of consumers the education club
I'm very involved with because I'm a
dual degree major with the School of
Education for two reasons one I think
with the changes of Technol in
technology that are occurring at a such
a fast pace a big part of marketing is
now going to be educating consumers so I
think you can learn a lot from learning
how to teach learning how people learn
basically and how to use that in
marketing
so like you not only have the
opportunity look into consumer focus
groups or companies your elbow aiso to
use those same skills and flex them out
in other industries or other areas that
you might not have exposure to after the
GSB and that's such an important skill
set to have I noticed that even though I
was in big tech and big oil and gas
companies what I learned is that often
times you have a company that's setting
the strategy and it could be a marketing
strategy but there's not enough
resources deployed to actually teach the
consumers or teach even the rest of the
business about how to get from point A
to point B so the education aspect is so
important and I think that's a trait in
a unique way to look at a dual degree
and then look at how you actually build
your skills having coming in with the
marketing experience that's like I can
teach someone use autonomous cars or how
do you like something that you can even
picture having it doesn't it part of
your everyday life how do you go about
starting something so drastically
different Hey
and I imagine that before coming here
you probably weren't even thinking about
how they try and convince someone about
how to use and exactly what is the
moment like are they already out there
yeah so it's another thing that we get
being here to Silicon Valley it's
wonderful well apart from clubs I just
be curious about career opportunities so
we talked about some of the clubs such
as the retail and consumer Club I know
that there's a lot of different treks
that those clubs take part on and to
make sure that you're able to go see
these companies see what roles are out
there so can you maybe talk a little bit
more about the BB LS or some treks that
you've been on and how that's opened
doors up into the Career Management
Center or into career opportunities so
BB ELLs and also what is a BB l yes so
it's so it's basically an hour during
lunch time where the GSB intentionally
doesn't schedule any classes so that
panniers or guest speakers or alumni can
come and be either host a panel or just
give a talk about a specific topic of
company the return on consumer club I
think hosts at least two or three a
month and so we have a lot of consumer
focused companies coming and those have
been extremely helpful because you get
to mean beyond what you hear from the
company you actually get to meet
generally the CEO or head of strategy of
the CEO and it's a good way to make an
introduction offer your thoughts about
the specific topic and create our
relationship and I know many of my
classmates and including myself have
managed to actually either serious
potential internships opportunities or a
past GSB full-time offer through there
yeah and I know for me I went to a
brown-bag lunch hosted by DFS group
which is a company that manages a number
of the duty-free stores that you see in
international airports especially across
Asia and we had had the VP of North
America come to visit and come to
discuss their business model and it
wasn't a company that I had been
considering previous to them coming to
campus but ended up talking having a
conversation offline with the VP and
North America and then ended up being
able to do an international internship
which is called a G mix which is a
global immersion program that's offered
by the Career Management Center and was
able to go over there for a month and
work in their international branding
team so like Christina was saying
there's so many different opportunities
that you're able to leverage from these
brown-bag lunches and a couple of ones
that have stood out to me have been both
the retail consumer club that has
already been mentioned a number of times
but also the marketing club we're
actually working on planning a track to
go visit some of these companies and how
we choose the companies is often by
looking at companies that are doing
really interesting things right now in
the space but also companies that are
looking to hire interns or hire
individuals who are full-time
career so we can start to prepare and
set people up to move into these spaces
so I'd be curious eyes on what what
really stands out to you and when
thinking about this I also really
enjoyed all the speakers that we get to
have on campus not only because it's
opportunities to interact with CEOs but
it's also opportunities to get into
their brains and understand the consumer
trends and the challenges that they see
in the areas in the next couple of years
sorry lolli and pops coming to campus
and a having just an insight into what
starting your own company in a very
consumer focused candy everywhere yeah
but it's very interesting to be able to
very quickly in an hour get something
like such a deep perspective of the
consumer trance is such a wider range
from retail to food and beverage to CPG
to blanking exactly and I know we talked
a little bit before earlier in the week
about the Career Management Center
offering a number of workshops and
sessions to help facilitate the job
search process so maybe you can talk a
little bit about stood out to you know
the one that was definitely useful for
me immediately was the - our job search
by Steve that I think it's Steve Dalton
do you don't have to be you consumer
focused person who benefit from the
course of from workshops like that but
that all the workshops that I found very
useful are very intentional in terms of
the terms of skill that they want you to
learn or what you're gonna want to get
out of so I also really enjoyed the how
to make memorable presentations or how
to network as an international student
or it was I think it's called how to
manage US networks so I think there have
all been very detailed very detailed
this is a skill that I'm gonna get in
one hour you go and you actually do get
end up getting that skill by the end and
then you're able to apply it to the job
search exactly afterwards
are there any trips so any trips that
really stand out you mentioned that you
haven't gone on any tracks Christina but
are there any trips such as maybe our
required Global Studies trip or other
experiences that you might
had that have landed way to learning
more about the consumer space and
multiple different countries across the
world besides just our little bubble in
the Silicon Valley I so many I recently
led GST to Mexico and one of the
meetings that we had was with Mexico CEO
for kimberly-clark and we had a panel
with him and a politician you talk about
how changes in regulation are gonna
affect the company then a coming year so
changes in afta or the new presidential
elections are gonna be happening in
Mexico and it's such an interesting
conversation we'll be able to have with
a CEO and a hika topology change from
the from a country you're not familiar
with Wow and how did you get that
meeting or get to lead this trip in the
first place yeah so he's an alum so we
were able to connect with him I might
have already slipped in that I was
interested in really quite I I really
admire the company so as a leader you
get to choose what companies you want to
incorporate on your trip so it's a great
opportunity to network with people that
you might not necessarily know how to
introduce yourself I'm having to take 25
MBAs that are interested in your
companies of great excuse to get to meet
anyone that you want in a new country
that's amazing what is your been your
experience with alumni outreach super
friendly I've never not gotten a
response from an alum basically it's a
pretty tight community I think that's
one of the benefits of having such a
small class but it's I've had the same
experience I know that for me a number
of the trucks that I planned are trips
that I've gone on is you reached out to
an alumni and if they don't respond
within a couple of days they send an
apology note that you know they're sorry
that it's taken so long but everyone's
been very very receptive and I know that
in the Career Management Center one of
the advisors there every time I go will
send me a list of alumni that says hey
reach out to this person and just grab
coffee or go to their office and see
what they're doing ask how they decided
their own career path and especially
transitioning into this space that's
been beyond valuable for me I was doing
a gbics in Tanzania and had a lot of
free time and surprisingly well my
nights correspond to very
early morning in a Sephora in the US and
I was able to have so many Skype
conversations with alumni in my free
time that I was super surprised like
just blinding reaching out to people in
Sephora and how surprised I was trying
to understand what I wanted to do after
I graduated and leveraging my summer
free time in a way to just hear about as
many people's experiences as I could
that's really nice I was able to do that
I'd be curious about any trips that
stand out or alumni connections that
have really helped you boost your career
especially transitioning from oil and
gas as well in consulting yes this
summer I was returning to San Francisco
I was doing also a global immersion
experience in Thailand at an ecommerce
startup and I stopped in London and I
just wanted to see what the
opportunities were where there and so I
reached out to just a couple of alumni
during you were in London one of them
wasn't even part of the consumer retail
space and within I think I don't know
like maybe 12 hours I was put in touch
with five people who were working in
companies that I could be interested in
and I managed to meet them within 48
hours in London all of them so even
abroad internationally I found that the
network is definitely there and people
are excited to help you out and that was
really pleasant surprise for me and
that's really important that it's not
just this table where people are helpful
but I'd be curious are you thinking
about potentially staying here after
school or why is that international
connection valuable for you um I guess
for me as an international I definitely
want to spend one year at least in the
u.s. after school but I want to keep
myself the option of going back to
London where I used to work and I think
in Europe there's a lot of a happening
in the consumer retail space it's a
smaller market more fragmented but
there's a lot of brands they are they're
interesting to me and so just nurturing
the
relationships and staying in touch over
the year those people are still there
and and it's not a transactional
exchange of emails very much like hey I
thought these could be of interest of
you like these are my thoughts and they
reply it's it's great and that's that's
the smartest thing to do I think that
probably one of the most valuable things
that we've all experienced here is just
being able to ask questions so part of
the learning process outside of the
classroom is just being immersed in
international perspectives and being
immersed in learning about
kimberly-clark in Mexico or planning
trips or be VLS and there's so many
different opportunities to immerse
ourselves and being able to learn more
about the space so what I'd like to do
is just shift a little bit into thinking
about career goals after school so we're
all interested in a space it most of you
the two of you have had experience over
the summer learning more about this
space through internships can you talk a
little bit about where you're thinking
about going after school sure so one
option for me is to go back into
consulting but this time in the consumer
retail space and I know that the option
is there one other option which is what
I'm personal right now is actually
starting my own brand it's like a
fashion brand and that's what has been
incredible to me has been the amount of
support that I've actually got here from
an academic point of view in terms of
classes that I'm taking that are
supporting my objective the professors
and the knowledge that they bring and
the mentoring that they do and then once
again the alumni network and the
willingness that they have in sharing
their learnings especially in in their
more in entrepreneurship space so those
are my two options I think there's time
it's like an evolving thinking process
there's time before graduation but I can
see how now you know options are
studying to sort of pop up in front of
you and you almost have you almost have
too many
options to choose I would say this I
think that was also extremely valuable
for me to see that you know despite the
fact that we are in this you know tech
tech focused area like steel there is
that there are so many opportunities for
people are interesting in the CPG
consumer retail space I think that's one
of the things to highlight is that
obviously we've all done the hard work
to make sure that those options are
there but even probably the person that
sent least amount of work has found that
there's multiple options and multiple
career paths in this space which has
been a huge opportunity I know for
myself and they're all so tempting yes
like it's so hard to be joyful and what
you want to do after the GSB because you
just get tempted by so many cool things
that you can do after your graduation so
I found the CMC super helpful in trying
to determine what is exactly that I want
out of my next job and how do I stay
true to that so I've had a lot of
one-on-one Commerce advising
conversations with advisors up at CMC to
really like write down in hearthstone
what is it exactly that I'm looking for
and what do I want out of my next job
and make sure that I don't let you guys
maybe you can share a little bit less
about what you're finding so after Owens
five months I'm gonna be doing a retail
leadership rotational program at I Mazon
I'll be able to test out different
career paths within a very customer
focused industry so I'll be rotating
between marketing operations third-party
vendors in different areas I like they
ability to be able to use a lot of the
skills that I've learned at the GSB so
like operations I'm not my my strengths
but being able to know how to do it is
so important just because as you move up
if you become a category leader you'll
have operations people reporting to you
so knowing what they do is super
important
so I really value having that broad
landscape of skills and experiences
which this rotational program is gonna
do for me I think that's fantastic and I
know you'll be able to use
the experience and basically the
proximity to where we are now to build
into that ecommerce platform so I think
that's fantastic and Christina you you
under understated a bit of what you've
been doing as well so Christina I'm
gonna take this opportunity to brag
about her has been working around the
clock and has really just heard us so
much interest from our classmates and
what she's been working on in the
entrepreneurial space and although its
entrepreneurial it's also very driven by
her consumer interest and I think the
opportunities that you've had any
exposure to everything in this area has
been beyond valuable and to say that
it's the community I think is the wrong
way to angle and I think that you've
just done a tremendous job driving that
forward and figuring out exactly where
your passions are and that's what yeah
these past years have really creative
yeah and Business School is such a risk
free environment to do so there's so
many of us that are you know testing
products the services not just in the
consumer retail space everywhere and we
work all together at coalesce which is a
shared working space there are ideas of
thering from corner to the other of the
room all the time and it's risk-free you
know that you can always you know go
look out there and find plenty of
opportunities but for some of us it
would be a full-time career
entrepreneurship will turn into
something definitely someone not that's
not doing an Anoop renewal role being
able to test out all the products that
is true and I know for myself I don't
plan to go the entrepreneurial route but
I'm still trying to figure out which
space is right for me I'm definitely in
the consumer space I think you just have
such a competitive advantage when you
can touch and feel the products and know
exactly who you're marketing for so
ideally I want to be a user of the
product I eventually that I eventually
end up marketing or of the company that
I end up working for so still trying to
figure that out but with that said I
love to just ask you guys one final
question if there's anything that any
type of advice that you would like to
recommend
they're students that might potentially
join the GSP community and he just
lasting words or her pieces of advice
for them I think that once you get into
the GSB you have so many opportunities
it's very overwhelming it's hard to
choose what courses you want to take
what extracurriculars you want to be
involved with my biggest advice is dream
big whenever you're trying to make
choices in terms of what skills do I
want to build what classes I want to
take think about the wildest role that
you think you might have it's like I'm
gonna be CEO of X and what do I need to
get there and then leverage the GSB to
do as much as you can to prepare
yourself for that huge big role that
you're gonna have one day I think that's
so truly for me it's be open-minded
if I had even guessed the number of
things that I'd be involved in two years
ago I think I would have been so far off
I mean I had the opportunity to write a
case on the mental health space and I
would have never said that I would do
that two years ago and then I've been
able to intern in a couple of really
incredible companies over the summer
focused on the consumer space and the
access that we get to a number of
leaders is just unbelievable so I just
say be open-minded don't limit yourself
don't come in with hard and fast rules
about what you have to do and won't do
for that matter but be open-minded set a
plan for what you really want to
accomplish and just go after it so I
think that I've learned the most from
those unexpected experiences and I think
that's the best advice that I can give
to anyone that's thinking about coming
here so with that I'd like to thank both
of you for being here today and we wish
you all a wonderful rest of your day
thank you
you